STOP DROP AND THEN REGAIN POWER.
AND THAT'S THE ANGLE.
JOINING US NOW REACTION FROM
BOSTON, JEFF BEATTY, RETIRED
DELTA FORCE OFFICER WHO ALSO
WORKED AS A COUNTERTERROR
OFFICIAL AT THE CIA.
AND I DON'T -- IDAHO, FORMER CIA
OPERATIVE MIKE BAKER AND HERE IN
WASHINGTON, RISIBLE, FORMER
OBAMA DEFENSE DEPARTMENT
OFFICIAL AND CURRENT SENIOR
FELLOW AT THE NEW AMERICA
FOUNDATION.
GREAT TO SEE ALL OF YOU.
MIKE, I BELIEVE YOU TRAINED WITH
GINA.
YOU CAN GIVE US A LITTLE INSIGHT
INTO HER AND HER EXPERIENCE.
WE DEMONSTRATED HOW DUPLICITOUS
THE DEMOCRATS ARE.
THEY SUPPORTED BRENNAN AND NOW
SUDDENLY GINA HASPEL IS A
PROBLEM.
BUT GINA HASPEL, HER WORK ETHIC,
HER EXPERIENCE, WHO SHE IS AS A
PERSON, YOU KNOW THIS WELL.
>> YEAH, WE WERE IN TRAINING AT
THE SAME TIME.
WHAT SEEMS LIKE A LONG TIME AGO,
THE BEGINNING OF OUR RESPECTIVE
CAREERS.
SHE OBVIOUSLY HAS EXCELLED WHERE
YOU COULD ARGUE MINE WAS
SOMEWHAT MEDIOCRE.
LOOK, EITHER WHAT YOU SHOULD BE
DOING IS TAKING THIS MONOLOGUE,
THE ANGLE, AND PUTTING ON A
CONTINUOUS LOOP BECAUSE IT IS
ABSOLUTELY CORRECT.
THE IDEA THAT SOMEHOW THEY ARE
ABLE TO NOW DRAW A SHARP DIVIDE
BETWEEN THE CONFIRMATION PROCESS
FOR JOHN BRENNAN, WHO I DO HAVE
A LOT OF RESPECT FOR.
WHILE EXPERIENCE OFFICER.
UNLESS THEY HAVE SOME DIFFERENT
STANDARDS FOR A MALE DIRECTOR
DESIGNATE AND A FEMALE DIRECTOR
DESIGNATE, AND I CAN IMAGINE
THEY DO.
THEN HOW DO YOU POSSIBLY EXPLAIN
THIS OTHER THAN, AS YOU POINTED
OUT, THE DIFFERENCE IS TRUMP.
AND I FOUND MOST INTERESTING OF
THE OPEN QUESTIONS THAT WERE
ASKED YESTERDAY IN THE OPEN
SESSION OF THE HEARINGS, THESE
QUESTIONS ABOUT, HOW DID YOU
FEEL ABOUT IT?
WHAT DID YOU THINK ABOUT IT?
WHAT REALLY COUNTS WHEN YOU'RE
TALKING WITH THE INTEL COMMUNITY
AND THE MILITARY AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT, WHAT ARE THE
LAWS ON THE BOOKS AT THAT TIME.
HOW SOMEBODY FEELS ABOUT IT
FRANKLY, I DON'T CARE.
AND I DON'T THINK THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC REALLY CARES WHAT THAT
FEELS ARE.
CAN YOU IMAGINE IF A COMBAT
BRIGADE OR YOUR OPERATIONAL
PEOPLE AND YOUR INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE GO OUT AND BASICALLY
ARE MAKING THEIR DECISIONS IN A
VISUALLY ON HOW THEY MAY FEEL?
>> Laura: THE VALUES QUESTION
CAME UP A LOT.
ROSA, I WANT TO GO TO YOU.
EVEN PEOPLE VERY CRITICAL OF
THIS PRESIDENT, PHILMONT, THE
CIA ANALYST ON CNN, HE WAS
ASKED ABOUT KAMALA HARRIS'
VALUES QUESTIONS TO GINA HASPEL.
HE SAID YOU THINK THIS IS MORAL
WHAT WAS BEING DONE.
SHE STAYED ON THE MORALITY
QUESTION.
THIS IS WHAT SHE SAID.
>> DO YOU BELIEVE THE PREVIOUS
INTERROGATION TECHNIQUES WERE
IMMORAL?
>> SHE SPOKE ABOUT AMERICAN
VALUES AND SHE SPOKE ABOUT RULE
OF LAW.
I APPRECIATE WHAT SHE VOTES ON.
SHE CAN VOTE HOWEVER SHE WANTS.
I DON'T APPRECIATE THE
COLLECTIVE AMNESIA.
>> Laura: COLLECTIVE AMNESIA,
OBVIOUSLY REFERRING, AND AGAIN
THAT'S A CONSISTENT CRITIC OF
THE PRESIDENT, COLLECTIVE
AMNESIA ON THE PART OF DEMOCRATS
WHO VOTED ENTHUSIASTICALLY FOR
JOHN BRENNAN.
>> LAURA, I THINK YOU'RE
HIGHLIGHTING THE FACT THAT
HYPOCRISY AND SPINELESS THIS ARE
BIPARTISAN VICES HERE.
I AM DISAPPOINTED IN GINA
HASPEL.
I THINK SHE DIDN'T ANSWER A
STRAIGHT QUESTION AND SHE OWES
US AN ANSWER TO THE STRAIGHT
QUESTION DO YOU THINK IT'S
IMMORAL.
SHE DODGED IT COMPLETELY.
BUT YOU ARE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
DO THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION SOFT
PEDAL THIS ISSUE?
WE ARE SEEING SCRUTINY OF GINA
HASPEL.
I THINK YOU'RE WRONG ABOUT WHAT
DILEMMA DEMOCRATS ARE FACING.
THE IRONY HERE IS THE DEMOCRATS
LIKE THE FACT THAT GINA HASPEL
IS NOT AN IDEOLOGUE.
SHE'S A PROFESSIONAL.
SHE'S NOT SOMEBODY WHO'S
CONVEYANCING I WANT TO ADVANCE
THE REPUBLICAN AGENDA.
SHE IS SINGLE FROM I JUST WANT
TO ADVANCE THE AMERICAN AGENDA.
DEMOCRATS LIKE THAT ABOUT HER A
LOT MORE THAN THEY LIKE MANY OF
TERMS POLITICAL APPOINTEES.
BUT THE DOWNSIDE IS THAT IF YOU
WANT THAT, YOU'VE GOT TO EMBRACE
SOMEBODY WHO SEEMS TO HAVE
EMBRACED TORTURE, WHICH
DEMOCRATS AREN'T --
>> Laura: SHE DIDN'T DESIGN
THE PROGRAM.
>> WELL, LAURA.
I HAVE TO THROW THE CHALLENGE
FLAG.
>> Laura: JEFF IS COMING IN ON
US WITH THE CHALLENGE FLAG.
>> I'VE GOT TO THROW THAT
CHALLENGE FLAG, ROSA.
TORTURE IS A PROPAGANDA WORD.
THAT'S A PROPAGANDA AND IT'S
CHOSEN TO EVOKE AN EMOTIONAL
RESPONSE.
IT'S CHOSEN TO CONJURE UP IMAGES
OF PUTTING PEOPLE ON THE RACK OR
CUTTING OFF FINGERS OR LIMBS.
LET'S BE ACCURATE.
LET'S NOT BE PROPAGANDA.
IF YOU TRAIN YOUR PEOPLE AT
GEORGETOWN TO USE PROPAGANDA
TERMS, YOU'VE GOT TO -- I DON'T
ALLOW MY STUDENTS USE LOADED
THING WHICH LIKE THAT.
LET'S TALK ABOUT WHAT IT IS.
IT'S NOT THE RACK.
IT'S NOT CUTTING PEOPLE'S
FIGURES OFF OR LIMBS OFF.
IT'S WATERBOARDING.
IF YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT
WATERBOARDING, LET'S TALK ABOUT
A VERY LET'S NOT GO FOR THE
SPECIFIC TO THE GENERAL.
AND THE GENERAL IS GENERALLY A
LOT MORE HEINOUS THAN WHAT WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT.
>> Laura: BUT JEFF, I THINK --
HOLD ON.
I THINK WHAT ROSA IS SAYING IS
THERE IS A CONVENTION AGAINST
TORTURE.
THERE IS A U.N. CONVENTION
AGAINST TORTURE.
HOWEVER WE SHIFTED OUR
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT THAT MEANS
AND AFTER 9/11, WE WANTED THE
INFORMATION.
AS YOUR FORMER COMMANDO
EXTREMES, WE WANTED THE
INFORMATION TO STOP THESE
ATTACKS.
IF ANYONE OF US WHO HAD A KID
WHO HAD BEEN KIDNAPPED AND ONE
PERSON KNEW WHERE OUR CHILD WAS,
WE WOULD SAY DO WHATEVER YOU
HAVE TO DO TO GET THAT
INFORMATION.
WE WOULD SAY THAT AS PARENTS, WE
KNOW THAT.
>> YES, YOU WOULD.
>> IT'S LIKE HAVING A PET DOG
AND YOU TRAIN THE DOG TO BRING
THE PAPER TO YOU AND THE DOG
DOES WHAT YOU WANTED TO DO,
FOLLOWED YOUR INSTRUCTIONS, AND
NOW YEARS LATER, YOU BEAT THE
DOG WITH THE PAPER.
YOU KNOW, IT'S LIKE, IS IT
LEGAL?
IT WAS, AND SHE DID LEGAL
PROCEDURE.
IT WAS INVESTIGATED TWICE.
FOUND TO BE LEGAL.
>> Laura: SHE IS EMINENTLY
QUALIFIED.
TO BE CIA DIRECTOR BY ANY FAIR
INDICATION OR EXAMINATION OF HER
BACKGROUND.
WHAT SHE FEELS AS A PERSON IS
FRANKLY NOT RELEVANT TO HER JOB
AS A PERSON IN CHARGE OF THE
THAILAND BLACK SITE.
HER FEELINGS.
WHAT IS THAT MEAN, YOUR
FEELINGS.
IT SUCH A DEMOCRAT, LIB WAY.
WHAT ARE YOUR FEELINGS?
ROSA HAS TO GET BACK IN.
MIKE, HOLD ON.
ROSA FIRST.
>> THIS IS NOT MY PROPAGANDA
WORD.
THERE'S REAL IRONY HERE.
IT'S FUNNY TO ME HOWEVER IS TALK
ABOUT THE WORLD WAR II
GENERATION IS THE GREATEST
GENERATION, SO AFTER
WORLD WAR II WHEN WE FACED AN
ABSOLUTELY EXISTENTIAL THREAT,
WE PROSECUTED IN THE TOKYO
TRIBUNALS TO MOWING PROSECUTOR
JAPANESE SOLDIERS FOR
WATERBOARDING U.S. SOLDIERS, AND
WE CALLED IT TORTURE THEN.
THE SAME WAY WE HAVE CALLED IT
TORTURE CONSISTENTLY.
THAT'S WHAT THE LAW CALLS IT.
IT'S NOT WHAT I CALL IT.
THERE IS A BRIEF PERIOD IN THE
BUSH OF ADMINISTRATION WHEN SOME
OF DICK CHENEY'S LAWYERS DECIDED
THEY DIDN'T WANT TO CALL IT
TORTURE BECAUSE THEY WANTED TO
BE ABLE TO DO IT.
THAT WAS REPUDIATED A FEW YEARS
LATER, EVEN BY THE BUSH OF
ADMINISTRATION.
>> Laura: CHENEY STILL SAYS WE
SHOULD BE DOING WATERBOARDING.
CHENEY WAS OUT THERE TONIGHT.
[ALL SPEAKING]
>> I CAN'T BELIEVE WE ARE NOT
CONCERNED THAT IT WAS APPLICABLE
CONCERNED THAT IT WAS APPLICABL
APPLICABLE.
>> Laura: LET ME GET TO MIKE
FIRST AND THEN WE WILL GO BACK.
>> THANK YOU.
I CAN'T BELIEVE WE ARE GOING
THROUGH THIS AND RELITIGATING IT
AGAIN WITH SOMEBODY WHO IS IS
EMINENTLY QUALIFIED IN THIS
POSITION AS GINA HASPEL'S.
LOOK, WHAT THEY DID SO WELL,
THOSE YEARS AGO WHEN WHEN THIS
WAS FRONT BURNER TOPIC, THE FAR
LEFT SEIZED THE MORAL HIGH
GROUND AND SAID EVERYTHING
EXCEPT TALKING TO A DETAINEE IS
TORTURE.
EVERYTHING.
NOW, I UNDERSTAND, OBVIOUSLY
IT'S AN EMOTIVE SUBJECT BUT
FRANKLY THAT'S NOT THE CASE.
THERE ARE AREAS, IT'S LIKE
EVERYTHING ELSE.
IT'S NOT THIS WITHOUT.
THERE ARE AREAS, AND THEY'VE
OBVIOUSLY REFERRED TO AS
ENHANCED INTERROGATION
TECHNIQUES, THAT EXISTED.
MAY I REMIND YOU OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE, OFFICE OF
LEGAL COUNSEL, WE DID ON THIS
REPEATEDLY AND CLEARLY AND ON
AND VIGOROUSLY.
AND NOW THAT INFORMATION PASSES
TO THE GENERAL COUNSEL.
THE AGENCY THAT WAS DISSEMINATED
TO THE FIELD.
CAN I POINT OUT ONE OF THE
THING.
THERE'S A WELL-WORN PATH BETWEEN
LANGLEY WHERE THE CIA
HEADQUARTERS IS AND
CAPITOL HILL, BACK IN 2002 AND
2003 GOING TO THE TALKING TO THE
GANG OF EIGHT.
>> Laura: I MADE THAT POINT.
THEY WERE BRIEFED.
NANCY PELOSI LEARNED ABOUT AT
THE SAME TIME GINA DID.
JEFF.
>> I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT HER
NICE ANOTHER ASPECT OF WHAT YOU
BROUGHT OUT IN THE ANGLE.
TALKING ABOUT THAT THIS IS MORE
ABOUT DONALD TRUMP THAN IT IS
ABOUT GINA HASPEL.
AND EVEN INTO THE REPUBLICANS
INVOLVED IN THIS, SALUTE TO
SENATOR McCAIN.
HE ACTUALLY ENCOURAGED ME BACK
MIDDAY TO RUN FOR SENATE WHICH I
DID.
MAYBE I SHOULD BE MANAGING FOR
THAT BECAUSE I GOT MY CLOCK
CLEANED HERE AGAINST JOHN KERRY.
I HAVE THE HIGHEST RESPECT FOR
HIM AND EVERYTHING THAT HE WENT
THROUGH.
BUT I THINK HE'S LETTING HIS
ANIMUS AGAINST PRESIDENT TRUMP
BLEED OVER INTO THIS.
I MEAN, YOU KNOW HE IS A STRONG
DISLIKE FOR THE PRESIDENT, AND
WHEN HE SAYS DON'T COME TO MY
FUNERAL, THAT'S A STRONG
DISLIKE.
AND I'M AFRAID THAT HE'S SO
RESPECTED THAT OUT OF RESPECT TO
HIM, THAN OTHER REPUBLICAN
SENATORS MAY ACCEDE TO HIS WISH
THAT IT DOES KNOW MANY OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP NOT GET
CONFIRMED.
AND I THINK IT'S A MISTAKE, AND
I HOPE THAT HE WILL CHANGE HIS
MIND ABOUT IT AND I HOPE HIS
COLLEAGUES WILL RECOGNIZE SHE'S
A PROFESSIONAL.
IT'S LIKE IF YOU'VE GOT A GREAT
GROUP OF PEOPLE, YOU WANT SOME
BUT HE KNOWS HOW TO BEST USE
THEM.
NOBODY KNOWS BETTER THAN SHE HOW
TO GET THE BEST OUT OF THE
AGENCY, AND WE ARE TODAY SHE'S
GOING TO RESPECT THE LAW.
>> Laura: GUYS, WE COULD HAVE